así es hola que tal un día después de
las elecciones de este balotaje en el
que cuatro regiones han elegido
gobernadores el país sigue sin saber
quiénes han sido los gobernadores
electos en estas justas y el tribunal
electoral ha señalado que tiene siete
días para dar los resultados oficiales
sin embargo debo comentarles que el
cómputo va demasiado lento en el caso
del departamento de la paz que es la
gobernación más grande el cómputo
avanzado apenas hasta el 32% y el
departamento que más avanzado es pando
con apenas un poco más del 60 por ciento
también sobre el ausentismo el
presidente del tribunal supremo
electoral el salvador romero ha señalado
que se ha producido un ligero ausentismo
en comparación a las elecciones de la
primera vuelta realizadas en marzo bueno
y un poco más de contexto porque se
consideran importantes nuestras
elecciones a cuatro gobernaciones qué
implicaciones tienen para el partido más
de gobierno especialmente tras la salida
de evo morales en 2019 qué significa
esto para bolivia
para el movimiento al socialismo son
unas elecciones importantes porque esto
le va a permitir calibrar su poder en
las regiones un poder regional
recordemos que en las recientes
elecciones municipales el movimiento al
socialismo ha perdido ocho de las diez
principales alcaldías del país y por eso
es importante que es lo que va a ocurrir
en las elecciones de las gobernaciones
en la primera vuelta el más ganó en tres
de las nueve gobernaciones y si en estas
elecciones es decir en esta segunda
vuelta logra el triunfo en estas otras
gobernaciones pues tendría un triunfo
seguro y casi redondo en las
gobernaciones pero si lo pierde será una
primera señal de que su poder empieza a
declinar el poder de evo morales y del
presidente luís arce